you know lately i've done things where
i've exposed myself to a lot of founders
and entrepreneurs
and i i'm just amazed
uh with that whole tribe so to speak
right they
stand with each other they are always
helping
uh while they are seeking help as well
obviously but
it's all about give uh win-win give and
take
and uh it's it's just amazing um
you know it's it's amazing welcome to 20
minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community-driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and
in media partnership with c-tech welcome
to another episode of 20 minute leaders
i'm honored to be joined today by vivek
kakar
previously senior director at cisco a
technologist
previously senior director in cisco
leading a number of big projects in
video collaboration devices wearables
webex etc
he's a lifelong learner now executing
his own leap
by helping startups and exploring his
own entrepreneurial ambitions
vivec has a natural passion for
improving leadership by understanding
the neuroscience behind social dynamics
in a workplace
vivek kakar thank you for joining me on
20 minute leaders how are you
i'm good michael thanks for having me
you have been serving
20 minutes of pure inspiration and i
love it
thank you for the cameras i don't think
anybody said something so kind on the
show yet so
now you've just set a new bar and i'm
really excited in the next 20 minutes to
get to know vivek better
and and a little bit about you know your
your feelings insights and experiences
from the tech scene
previously senior director at cisco
you're also working on some phenomenal
projects of your own
a mentor to various startups but
there's different things that we want to
talk about today and i'm going to let
you
start off a little bit about your
journey and some of the things that you
personally find interesting in the way
you look
at the leadership and the tech ecosystem
yeah so my journey started as an
engineer and a technologist i feel i'm
still
an engineer in my heart
my journey took me to leading global
teams
leading complex projects you know cloud
native
mobile apps variables hardware devices
and so on
and i believe in my last six years of
journey
i have been actually functioning as an
intrapreneur
basically you know the way i define that
is
somebody who is leading a team
amidst certain uncertainty with respect
to technology and business and how do
you navigate
similar to what a startup or an
enterprise would do
and that has been really rewarding and
both myself and my team has learned
a great lot from that experience
i personally like to solve problems but
the
biggest thing which drives me is the
customer obsession
you know surfing up serving up great
uh experiences and workflows for our
customers right so that has been a focus
also in the journey and like i
mentioned uh learning and growth both
for me and my team
both technology as well as all the
uh other aspects of of the journey
one thing i want to call out in that
journey is the
understanding of human behaviors and
social dynamics in a global setting in a
team setting
and what neuroscience brings
as a limelight into that aspect you know
i i fundamentally believe
that neuroscience and neural leadership
should be taught uh to everybody
maybe in undergrad or in at some point
of time and
what that allows you to do is to able to
actually understand the science
behind high performance teams and
higher engagement in people so so that
has been
that particular aspect has been really
interesting and rewarding for me
good successes as well as uh you know
great understanding around that
and then um you know having been in big
enterprise for some time
i have uh recently started to
actually you know delving into
helping startups through some
accelerators
and understanding you know how startups
function
how farmers function and how
how i can help as a as a technology
leader so
that has been a very rewarding uh
moments for me recently and
uh you know it's uh that's that's where
i am
and actually you know uh
i'm a good resource for anybody who
actually puts a lot of weight behind
learning and feels that they are too old
to
maybe learn something new um i don't
feel that way i think i think we can
learn and
deliver something exciting every day
as we are living i love it now you're
talking about
neuroscience and leadership being taught
you know in a traditional setting
to two subjects that one one feels very
you know it requires a lot of domain
expertise and many years
to to even understand the basics of it
the other one
feels like something that is very
unordinary to be thinking of in a
traditional setting
when you say you know leadership and and
you know the way neuroscience plays into
it
what do you actually mean what does that
mean to you
so fundamentally each one of us
you know we actually not only bring
cognitive ability to workplace
we also bring our emotions and in fact
if we don't bring our emotions then we
are no longer as engaged as we should be
right
so when you bring your emotions
you know you have a social dynamic which
plays there and if an environment
is conducive for the right social
dynamic
which allows people to actually feel
engaged
and feel really excited about their work
then they deliver more and they actually
are just a better people and better
teams
now as a leader how do you recognize
these forces
how do you enable environments
and behaviors is what this neuroscience
and your leadership is all about
and that's fundamental i believe and
leaders and people who understand it are
are slightly better in their day job and
their functions
is is what i believe
and so they i always like to think of
the pain
and you know from a young startup mind
the pain that you're seeing obviously in
articulating is that
not enough people that are engaged and
we're talking about a population of
people that are
highly engaged they're highly emotional
because that's at the end you know we
want to do things that we're passionate
about
with that passion you know comes the the
the difficulty and the challenge of
managing that
those emotions and and leading you know
in the army we used to call 360 degrees
up down and horizontally as well
and so why why is it in your mind
something that we can't just you know
through experience just grow
and automatically understand
it's a multi multi-phase phenomena so
you know things as important as
do the people understand the vision
are you as a leader propagating it
clearly
so that they are not confused you know
anything
which blocks their thinking brain or
confuses their thinking brain
is going to be a problem it could be a
big problem it could be a small
but for for ultimate
performance things need to be purely
aligned so
it starts from the vision
they need to be able to satisf get
satisfaction from
the fact that hey what i do every day
is paramount and most important for me
to do
for my company so it starts from that
right
so as a leader understanding that and
enabling that
through the organization scaling it
through the organization right
that's number one number two is on a
daily basis
are people able to bring their
best creative self to the work
or are they in a threat mode
is the environment creating threat modes
in their head
you know is there an issue with
layoffs is there an issue with their
sense of status
is there an issue of you know my
managers are not right
or you know my peers are not valuing me
you know
all these things able to spot these
problems
able to actually you know be able to
help when these problems
exist and sometimes even proactively
uh propagate the culture and values
so though so that the maximum
problems don't occur right uh that's
where it's very important for a leader
to be able to
be aware and also recognize
when any of these things may happen and
how do you mitigate it how do you scale
it right right
and that's why you know
you may think yeah this is very
intuitive this should be
omnipresent but unfortunately it is not
and leaders who are naturally more tuned
to this
i find them to be very effective they
are very approachable
they are more successful
that sounds you know on paper really
really nice this idea that
we can you know get those skills we can
become more aware we can be more
effective leaders
and i read recently a book and
about leadership from a military
perspective in the united states
by two generals that talked about
leadership in all its capacities a lot
about emotional intelligence and i feel
that
a lot of what you're touching on here
and we're not talking about you know
domain expertise we're not we're talking
here about human to human collaboration
understanding that what teamwork really
is all about
so in today's world for example a young
entrepreneur
i will soon you know sometimes start my
startup
how can i as a leader hold myself
accountable
to these skills and be able to both
question whether i'm you know improving
on them
but also have some checks and balances
like like
other like big organizations have how
can i do that as a
you know as a young entrepreneur yeah i
think you know i
i really like what david rock who has
uh also he's the founder of neuro
leadership institute
he came up with uh certain forces which
actually create
threat in any organization whether it's
a startup or a big enterprise
and he calls it scarf basically
you know as a as a founder or as a
startup entrepreneur
if you can make sure that
scarf is i'll explain what scaff is but
if these forces are in check
or in right order then people in general
will
not be in a threat situation and will be
highly engaged and performing
and basically scarf is an acronym for
status
so people in your team they are feeling
the value
they they bring something they feel good
about that
and they are recognized and valued so
status
second is certainty that they understand
their purpose they understand their
connection to the vision
and they understand where we are going
as a team whether you are a small or a
big team
third is a which is autonomy you know
they have the right autonomy at their
levels to be able to be
uh empowered right to perform and to
deliver
right and then r is relatedness right
they are feeling that they are part of
the team uh
you know they are not an outsider and
all that right
it's like i'm part of the club i'm part
of the team and so on
and the last is f which is fairness
that hey you know it's
it's a diverse team every everybody is
included everybody is valued
it's not about race it's not about
religion it's not about a club or a
friend or anything
everybody is equal this is so
fundamentally
correct and important but it's
it's it's like hey yes this is normal
this is natural but
understanding it and making that happen
on the ground
will do everything will do all the magic
no that makes that makes a lot of sense
it's obviously it gets more and more
valuable as the team grows and as the
complexity grows
but i imagine that understanding the
importance of it and
and and growing as a leader is important
from day one right
i see sometimes people saying yeah
you're right i'm the ceo of the company
but
but you know i'm not yet a leader now
and my perception is a little bit
different from the moment
you know the moment you've chosen to
take the responsibility
in any capacity you are need to hold
yourself responsible as a leader
as if you're in the battlefield right
exactly
exactly it's it's and it's a multiple
hats you know especially
being after doing a lot of
entrepreneurship within big organization
uh when i work with startup founders
and look at them
i mean in a good way they are toddlers
they need a lot of help
a lot of things are happening and
you know they are juggling a lot of
balls and
you know awareness of this sword
can be considered as luxury but
i think it's very fundamental as as a
as a person as a ceo and as a leader so
be able to execute it naturally
is is a good practice to have and
uh you know it can it can result in
in a great company so i'm really curious
when you sit down
with an entrepreneur you don't have to
give specific examples but when you're
sitting down with entrepreneurs
how how do you give sort of that that
mirror
or how do you how do you provide that
you know
that conversation starter to even talk
about these things do you find that
you know they're very open to it do you
find that they're very aware do you need
to bring more of
the awareness in how does the dynamic
you know work with you
so yes i think
i think the reason people found
companies one of the reason is they
are sponges they are very open they are
growth oriented and they have that
mindset of growth
and yes they are very receptive
but they also attach it to
revenue or what it does to their company
at that moment
so what i've also found is
you know depending on the phase where
the startup is top of their mind
top three things on their mind is not
this
right it will be how do i grow how do i
grow
in north america or asia or things like
that how do i
how do i generate more more funding for
example
or or how do i you know
grow my trials or things like that it's
it's more on that
at the early startup phase and less
about
you know scaling a team now that phase
comes
and that comes for every startup when
they're scaling the team and more than
that they are actually scaling globally
that's when this becomes really
important so
depending on the phase of the team phase
of the
organization this may not be the prime
top three things in their mind and at
that point of time
this conversation is really not
really central and and that's okay
you know but if they are aware that that
this will happen this will come and they
are aware of it
i think that's good enough
so what i'm hearing is that there's this
fine balance um
or almost like a tipping point where as
a startup entrepreneur and as a leader
you also you not just have to be
conscious of your own leadership
you also have to be conscious of what
are the priorities within that
leadership which makes it just even more
complicated
because now you not only have to be
aware of the draw of
you know your limitations and where you
need to improve but you also need to
acknowledge okay what should i focus on
improving right now is it the team
is it myself is it our product and it
sounds like
uh primarily i'm guessing a lot of help
is by talking about with others and with
and understanding
uh and the credit that you give a lot of
entrepreneurs i'm hearing is that
they're they're like sponges they're
coming in wanting to learn
wanting to be open-minded and wanting to
improve right
absolutely absolutely and it's it's
really
it's very very uh
rewarding to um you know lately i've
done things where i've
exposed myself to a lot of founders and
entrepreneurs
and i i'm just amazed
uh with that whole tribe so to speak
right they stand with each other
they are always helping
while they are seeking help as well
obviously but
it's all about give uh win-win give and
take and
uh it's it's just amazing um you know
it's it's amazing
i love it vivek are you ready for a few
fun questions a little bit different
from what we talked about until
now absolutely
wonderful okay we'll start easy we'll
get a little bit more complicated and
i'm
i'm also curious to hear some of the
reasoning behind
the responses we'll start off with your
favorite subject in school
we're talking about you know high school
middle school
yeah no so i
i basically you know leaned towards
engineering and math
fairly early and uh my dad was an
engineer mechanical engineer
and um you know that's where i leaned
although i'll tell you my favorite
subject
probably is and was world history
and the reason is
you know it's it's funny and actually
it's more clear now
than when i was in high school because
now i'm more global
what what is the most important truth
about world history is
it is it's a variable it's not constant
it changes
depending on the beholder which part of
country you are which
part of world you are the same world
history
is said and projected differently and
that is just
very interesting in my head you know and
after
uh after coming to us and actually uh
met
a lot of people from a lot of countries
this is actually even more true
yeah i love it vivek a second question
one of your role models or somebody that
inspires you
so i take inspiration from
wherever it comes you know that's my
strength so to speak but
i want to call out two role models
specifically
and i'll tell you why uh one is my
mother and she taught me
uh everything about continuous learning
and specifically she did her phd when
i was in my middle in high school and
i saw her working hard through that and
and that has given me the sense of
learning and growth uh as a continuous
process
so that's one inspiration i take from
her
and the second person is my
one of my managers who
taught me how to be an excellent coach a
empathetic coach and i believe
i was able to actually grow as a coach
as a people leader
because of him i think about him
whenever i
i'm in a situation around people things
that i think about him so that's a huge
huge learning from him
so those are the two people i will call
out
sounds like a true leadership you know
given especially what we talked about
until now
and the most and weirdest i should say
question
three words that you would choose to
describe yourself or if i were to ask
anybody
who are you
well it's a cliche but i i call myself
as a lifelong learner
um and it's basically again like i said
it's a continuous improvement
you grow you look at yourself from
outside
and i think you yourself can
fundamentally
pick what you want to grow in multiple
things at the same time
and go after those and i think it
requires
understanding of yourself
self-evaluation
and i believe i do that and i also
stay on the fine line where you don't
want to be too critical of yourself
but still want to be able to recognize
the
things you want to work towards
rebecca thank you so much for joining me
this was so enjoyable
and 20 minutes go by very very quickly
especially when we have such fun
conversations so thank you for
thank you for coming and and for the for
sharing these insights which
i'm taking i'm going to take with myself
for a long time especially on my own
journey and i believe that a lot of
others will as well so thank you very
much for coming
and stay safe and stay healthy
i enjoyed every moment of it michael
thank you so much